merci monsieur le président messieurs
les commissaires mais mes chers
collègues
à mon tour je voudrais commencer par
saluer deux choses particulières la
première c'est l'énorme travail dense et
très intense de notre collègue artis
pabriks sur ce rapport et deuxièmement
l'aboutissement de ce travail en un
temps record de ce dossier qui comme
vous l'avez rappelé ce soir était un
dossier clé un des rares dossiers dont
nos concitoyens ont vraiment entendu
parler et dont ils comprennent le sens
très concret la preuve est ici apporter
que lorsqu'il ya une volonté politique
lorsque l'union européenne veut réagir
et agir s'adapter aux situations même
les plus redoutables tel ce défi qui est
le nôtre et qui risque de mettre en
péril toute la construction européenne
est bien l'union c'est ça être force de
proposition et apporter des réponses
adaptées à la situation telle que elle
apparaît quelques points rapides dans le
peu de temps qui m'est donné quatre
points essentiels
un premier point c'est que nous avons là
une avancée indéniable qui vise à
remédier à la lacune principale de
frontex jusqu'à présent le manque de
ressources budgétaires mais aussi et
surtout de ressources humaines puisque
frontex disposera désormais d'une
réserve en solidarité entre états
membres de 1500 personnes mobilisables
très rapidement et qui aura en outre
cette agence la capacité de d'acquérir
du matériel propre et de s'en servir
très rapidement deuxième point la
mention claire de la compétence de
frontex en matière de recherche et de
sauvetage en mer avec monsieur patrick
scellés et les shadows rapporteur nous
nous sommes vivement battu sur cette
référence et nous l'avons obtenu
rappelons ici que nous avons
l'obligation fondamental de sauver les
vies humaines près de dix mille
personnes sont mortes en méditerranée
depuis 2014
et je ne parle pas des milliers de
personnes naufragés et dont trois sans
quatre enfants décédés depuis septembre
2015 troisième point de nombreuses
garanties en matière de droits
fondamentaux et le renforcement de la
responsabilité claire deux fronts film
d'anne frank aux légumes kris meeke